(gentle piano music)
- I remember the first time I jumped in
I was scared to death.
You know that it has
the power to mangle you
in a second.
But it chooses not to,
and that fascinates me.
My name is Andreas B. Heide.
I'm a sailor, adventurer,
and a marine biologist from Norway.
This is my third season in northern Norway
where I spent the winter
with my boat Barba.
It's harsh and it's also
tremendously beautiful.
There is no sign of people.
To me it's nature at its very best.
(upbeat music)
Our goal for this season is to
make a documentary about
orcas and whales in the wild.
What makes interaction
with orcas so special
is that you know that it's the
apex predator of the sea,
this has a tremendous power.
Often we have to observe
them from distance,
and at some points they are relaxed
and you can approach them,
and that's when you get them playful.
They're so gentle, yet so fast,
and they're so powerful yet
so very calm and peaceful.
To me, these whales and the era they're in,
they're kind of the pinnacle
of interacting with nature.
Once you've made eye contact with an orca
there is no turning back.
It's a moment you never forget.